hello everyone my name is Tamara
chambers and this is Tamara's never seen
Tim Tober fist a couple weeks back I
watched along with some friends all nine
of the Hellraiser films in one sitting a
friend of mine Jake Jarvey makes videos
once a year called the night marathon
where he watches every single movie and
a certain franchise in one day and then
time lapses the video check it out here
if you're interested this was the sixth
year doing it I've done two with him we
did all the Chucky films two years ago
and then this year a lot to talk about
most of it bad so I'm not gonna do any
predictions with this one check it out
next time on my Twitter page I always
ask for you to predict what I think imma
like we're not like about the film so
let's just dive right in to this towba
first I'm someone who loves horror films
and I had never seen any of the
Hellraiser films which is weird
I have seen all Halloween's all the
Nightmare on Elm Street sever all the
big movie franchises for horror and
Howry there had slipped past me somehow
I mean thank the Lord because it's bad
it's crazy to me how iconic pinhead is
as a character he's in the first two
films a lot arguably also the third and
then after that he is in the films for
two minutes and it's not about him he's
on the cover of all nine of the covers
he is the cover how you gonna be on the
cover when you have two minutes of
screen time it's a good game Doug
Bradley who played a laser in the first
eight films read the night film script
and said nope that's garbage can't do it
so they had to cast another human is to
play Arthur in the ninth film there are
supposed to be it might be out by the
time this video is released a tenth
Hellraiser film
the only reason why they're making them
at this point in time so they don't lose
the rights to it they don't make one
every three years they lose the rights
to Hellraiser which wouldn't be a bad
thing I don't think I think maybe let it
go maybe maybe it's time to let it go
it's time to let it go so let's start
from the beginning and work our way to
the end however either one definitely my
favorite by far no not by far he'll
raise our two pretty damn good liked it
a lot but I think Hellraiser one had
more focus it's like a classic horror
film is what it feels like it came out
an 80 something 87 the effects are
awesome when Frank comes out of the
booting attic ground and like builds up
into this skeleton it's cool as hell to
really has that same aspect of ore and
cool effects and just disgusting this in
a way that's different from like the Saw
films where it's just like too real
maybe I don't know if that makes sense
it's it's in a way that it's fun to
watch did it scare me no did any of the
nine films scare me not a chance
not at all but at least one and to have
a feeling of horror 1 and to feel like
Hellraiser films it's about the
Cenobites mainly pinhead coming when
he's summoned from the box which has a
cool name the lament configuration
that's such a good name so when the
lament configuration is opened and
figured out in the right way
the Cenobites come and they take you for
the ultimate pain versus pleasure I
don't see the power aspect of it but it
is very BDSM where they put hooks in you
and you're bound and I guess that's
where the pleasure comes in but they're
also ripping the skin off of your face
which you know nah I'm not kink shaving
here kink away my friends but that
doesn't do it for me but the first two
films have that he's summoned and the
Cenobites come and they take you away
and there's some hilarious 80s acting
and 80s looks why don't you were fun it
started the day off right then you get
into three which is not good let's just
be honest it's not
but it's still trying to be somewhat of
a Hellraiser film even though a lot of
things are not right one of the Stein of
bytes like throw CDs to kill this DJ and
then he turns into a DJ Cenobite n it's
just very it loses the like lore and the
like creepy effects of this other
dimension when there's a santa bite
throwing CDs at you and that's how you
die kind of loses the effect of it the
makeup is still cool even though it's
lame Santa by it still looks great in a
sense still trying to keep it up then we
go into for origin story of the lament
configuration and it's got Adam Scott's
who I love he's in Parks and Recreation
he's in Krampus he's in a little evil on
Netflix and he's in hell raiser for
there's something about that that just
delights me to my core if I ever met him
that would be the first thing that I
would ask Adam Scott what do you think
about hub racer
also have you seen the other Hal razor
if it was just so many question uh also
your great love yeah but don't kiss any
other women except for Lesley oh please
ruin the illusion ruin it there's cool
aspects of it a start torturing people
and then then you meet this doctor who's
the surgeon who is using people from
this insane asylum as what is what is
happening cool cool cool cool fine great
aspects to it that he turns into a Santa
bite awesome makeup very cool Cenobite
but then he kills pinhead it doesn't
make any sense I can't even remember it
honestly I had started drinking beer at
this point in the day as well so
so up until for their there they're
still trying at least to kind of be
Hellraiser films and then it just jumps
off into this the people I was watching
with kept saying Jacob's Ladder which I
haven't seen surprised shocked I know
but they said it was kind of that kind
of thing where it really turned into
like this weird cop thriller in in five
and six
five I pretty much slept through but I
got the gist of it six was actually kind
of interesting
it had chaos from the Insurance
commercials that's cool not chaos he's
also in 30 rock he's a bad actor but to
be fair I don't know how well I would
fare in the six Hellraiser film either
so not really going too hard on him
there then you get to seven which is
just complete horse garbage finally has
a female lead that we're following
around so slow and I really wanted to
like it cuz she's a great actress Carrie
were her forever
she did great but again a very like you
think something's happening but it
really isn't no we knew that it wasn't
happening also none of this is about
pinhead and he's on the cover of the
film Hellraiser 8 evil goes online
stupid as hell but at least fun it has
Superman in it Henry Cal calvess
something got a twenty percent on Rotten
Tomatoes which is fair that's fair they
got an invitation online and it's about
this guy getting revenge for his son's
death through Hellraiser tactics pinhead
is in it for like two minutes is way
more of a like a slasher Figg lengthy
flick then a Hellraiser flee it's none
of these since four has even tried at
all to be Hellraiser and flicks it's not
like he doesn't come out when he's
summoned by the lament configuration he
just comes to kill people and then right
before he does he gives like a long
speech that's
really what you think is deep when
you're in sixth grade he kills yup it
was stupid but fun and then nine-nine
was like 75 minutes like so short this
was the film that the actor playing
pinhead could not do and he has not been
doing winners like he's been saying yes
to some stinkers of movies but he could
not do this film because it was so bad
and the new person they got to play
pinhead I know nostalgia critic fans got
mad when dub changed wall colors it's
like that's a big deal this is a way
bigger deal like you know what I'm
saying like when change happens it can
be a little jarring but it's like just
get over it it's fine no this was too
much man it was like half found a
footage really awkward family dynamic
and 100% terrible acting not a
Hellraiser film at all
there is something satisfying about
having said that I've seen every single
film in that series let me tell you not
worth it don't watch him if you haven't
watched him don't watch up no he'll was
raised the only thing that was raised
was my hand with my beer glass also a
lot of Daddy a lot of people say daddy
and this whole entire franchise a lot of
come to daddy also a lot of fingers
touching lips and like going in mouths
with blood all over them this is my
official rating of the film's goes 1
then 2 then 6 then 8 5 4 3 then 9 so
list I hoped I'd never would have to
make I have had a blast with October I
just wish that I had a series talking
about horror films they loved them so
much and they excite me to no end I've
got some really good ones coming up
Karate Kid Lethal Weapon things like I
will see y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you